creating an indoor heart garden is
something you should try you don't need
to use soil and worry about soil
amendments moreover using fresh house
will make your dishes more nutritious
and tastier
growing procedure for all of the hearts
is similar
simply take some healthy fresh cuttings
and remove all the leaves except a few
at the top of it then submerge the
cuttings in a couple of inches of clean
water
now here are the top most popular herbs
that only needs some light and a jar of
water to thrive
number one basil nothing is better than
some fresh basil
and basil plants produce abundance of
leaves
this popular italian herbs grows well in
water
and can be used in different recipes
including sauces and soup
make sure your basil plants get plenty
of sunlight for its growth
number two seeds seize is popular for
its
excellent holistic flavoring properties
you can also use it into your favorite
dishes anytime
says grows well in moderately bright and
airy places all year long number three
rosemary this is a flavorful herb
that can grow under sunlight and shady
areas
although it will grow better in full
sunlight you can use your growing
to spice up your regular dishes by
rosemary
number four peppermint it's a quiet
low maintenance herb that does well in
partially sunny and shady areas
you can enjoy this sweet scent herb by
adding a bit
into your herbal tea well or soup number
five time thyme is a versatile herb and
excellent using in soup stove and pasta
they love to grow in plenty of sunlight
so keep the jars of
time in a bright window number six
oregano oregano is one of the popular
cooking essential and can be used in
pasta sauce dipping sauces and other
various savory dishes
and of course it can grow well in water
number seven stevia stevia is a
sweetener herb that can be a great
substitute for sugar
you will love to add this hub to sweeten
your tea or coffee
stevia plants usually prefer ample of
sunlight to flourish
number eight lavender lavender is
another easy growing hub with
lovely fragrance which will be floating
throughout your home
it's really popular to use in teas and
harvard
number nine photos both is also one of
the popular hubs which help to purify
the air by absorbing formaldehyde
benzene and carbon monoxide along with
eliminating odors
it prefers low lights for growing better
and finally number 10 lemon burn
it's a medicinal and flavorful herb you
can use to make an herbal tea that helps
to reduce
anxiety and symptoms of indigestion and
make sure to provide plenty of sunlight
to this plant to flourish
for continuous harvest of all of your
health you can add some hydroponic
nutrients to the water
as a nutrient boost for the plant now if
you ever grown any of the house in water
please share your experience in the
comments below
i hope this video was informative and
helpful if you liked the video give it a
thumbs up and if this is your first time
to visit my channel please subscribe for
more videos
thanks for watching